hi drew hi garcelle um i got married
about 10 months ago um and my husband
and i we have a five month old son
um i have two daughters from a previous
relationship and my ex he does a really
great job
helping with the kids we've come a
really really long way
we even joke from time to time that it
feels like we're brother and sister
so my question is i want to know how i
can get
my ex and my husband to coexist um
where it doesn't feel like we're in an
awkward situation
is it cantankerous now is it a little
like uneasy awkward
tension um
it's not really tension
it's just like avoidance like they kind
of like
seem to just avoid each other okay um
it's just very awkward like they don't
want to coexist firsthand what do you
think
oh i think it's always awkward i think
it's always awkward um
last year i had i was dating someone and
i decided for the first time
that i was going to bring my ex-husband
who's always with us for thanksgiving
and
the guy that i was dating and let me
tell you
it was so awkward at one point i went to
the pantry and took a shot at tequila
and took a deep breath and came back out
um i think the awkwardness is going to
be there until they do it more and more
you know i think it's tell you know
having a conversation with each
and each of them saying separately you
know let's put the kids first
let's do the best we can i think once
you address the elephant in the room
that may help and you know your new
husband's not going anywhere and your ex
isn't going anywhere
so i think it's beautiful that they're
willing to be in the same rooms
so talk it out with them and say let's
put the kids together and you know when
you're talking to one
bring in the other one you know what do
you think about this so that they feel
that they can
have a conversation but i get it i get
it girl it is awkward but it's okay
it's all for the betterment of the kids
think give it time too like the more you
force
the more they'll resist and if you find
yourself
in this space in a while from now and it
just you know in your gut and your heart
it's just been too long and
you know it's just not going well at
that point
like readdress it but for now just try
to let it go
and accept their approach
reaction behavior in this yeah do they
have anything in common do they like us
uh a certain sports team or
anything they can nothing they're like
well they're
completely opposites they are different
in a lot of ways um
so that's i think the most thing that
that will draw them together
are the children and and i really thank
them too because
even though they they don't like
acknowledge the coexisting um
situation they put the kids first
so i'm really grateful for that can i
ask a question and by the way this is so
much harder for me to practice
then preach just be you do your thing
don't try so hard to sell it your
attention
you might be the one bringing the
tension just
like this is as good as it's gonna get
right now
and there are horror stories out there
i'm sorry but it's true
so if you're not living in one that's a
win
yes yes exactly the fact that they're
willing to be in the same
room together in the same area together
is huge and the fact that they're
putting the kids first
um you have a really good thing and i
agree with drew give it time
and let them figure it out their grown
man let them figure it out
thank you ladies i really appreciate
that thank you
for sharing this because i'm sure
there's a lot of other people which is
why i was excited to talk to garcelle
today because
a lot of us are in this boat and we're
just trying to do the best we can
and figure it out and communicate and
let each other
know that you're not alone and here's
some thoughts and
ideas and approaches and so
thank you garcelle um thank you drew
it's been so fun to do this with you you
too
anytime all right well
garcelle buffet be sure to check out
garcelle's
three-part book uh series uh called
i am and also check her out weekdays
on the reel check your local listings
just like our show
you